[Music]
right Luna thank you so much for being
here with me oh thank you for having me
so Luna I want to start by talking about
what exactly does your company do so at
Genesis bio we take organic waste all
kinds of forms food waste or Industrial
Waste and we convert that into
compostable Plastics very cool how did
you get the idea for this so back during
my master's program in University of
Toronto I had a chance to visit a biog
gas facility where they convert food
waste into biog gas and then very
quickly I realized that throughout the
entire process there's these really
great carbons you can get from food
waste that can also be fed to much more
efficient bacteria to make higher value
products instead and that's how we
started so were you nervous about taking
the leap into entrepreneurship at first
or how did that come about for you not
really actually so back in University I
had a chance to start co-found two
software companies and it was there that
I learned a lot about how to build a
business and uh I always knew that I
wanted to found a company ever since
graduation so so I went for it very cool
who are your customers tell me a little
bit about who you're making this for
absolutely so traditionally our
customers has been B2B customers so
large cpg Brands like novel nordis canun
lver but this year we're actually
planning to launch our own products
directly to Consumers so it'll be really
exciting to see that what type of
products uh in the food and beverage
space as well as in the Cosmetic space
with ph very cool that's awesome and who
do you see as your biggest competitors
and how are you standing out from them
so our biggest competitors are other
people who also make compostable
Plastics like pla or seawe based ones
right now I think that there's actually
a really great space for everyone and
the phas the plastic that we make is
called phas which stands for polyhydroxy
aloid what's really special about them
is that they're a thermoplastic that can
be formed let's say by injection moding
or blow moding and it can also de great
a nature within less than 12 months so I
think that's the sweet space that phas
really do well in so do other Plastics
or or bioplastics than not degrade or
how how is it different good question so
usually other bioplastics usually
degrade really fast but they can't be
injection molded or blow molded very
easily or they degrade over a longer
period of time and they can be injection
molded and blow molded pH is one of the
only Plastics that can sort of do both
gotcha so talk to me about your
fundraising Journey how'd you get to
where you are today um so I think I
think we're really lucky to have a lot
of great investors backing us so for
example series a we raised last year
with COA Ventures leading the round and
then uh earlier this year we had Amazon
pledge fund uh co-lead our series a
extension and we're also backed by y
combinator so just really really great
to be connected with all these amazing
people what's your total funding right
now uh we have raised roughly $17
million to date then we also have
roughly $15 million of grant funding
fantastic and I I want to get a sense of
the the scale of your company can you
talk to me a bit about either customers
or sales or anything like that that'll
help me understand absolutely so this
year we have roughly around uh $5
million in revenues plus around $10
million in purchase orders and
additional deals that we have signed um
in terms of the impact that we can have
we really do think that next year is
going to be a big year for us because
Beyond just the B2B sales we will be
launching those products direct to
Consumers and that's where we do believe
that we can do a lot more better job in
terms of marketing it and uh bringing
about a new new type of plastic to the
world yeah what would you say is the
most challenging part of running your
company
so I'd say the most challenging thing
that we have running this company is
figuring out where are all the top
players in the world in terms of various
aspect that is relevant to our business
and bringing them on board so that we
can build a great thing together uh it's
often times really difficult to find
Talent U being in Canada originally and
that's why this year we're actually
looking to expand our operations into
the US and hopefully being able to tap
into greater Talent Hubbs when you say
expand to the US are you doing new
manufacturing plants or how are you
looking at the expansion yeah so we're
really thinking that we would start in
the basic lab research uh in Boston
specifically and then also being able to
partner up with really great people in
Los Angeles for example influencers Etc
that I'm really hoping to actually meet
in throughout this conference very cool
how would partnering with creators and
influencers help your brand so we really
look up to Brands like impossible Foods
who's really done an amazing job in the
past by bringing about plant-based Meats
to the world right and we do believe
that if we can get the top influencers
in the world we can help build a great
brand and also tell a great story that
people are uh people can relate to in
the plastic space now I love that you're
based in Canada can you talk to me about
how being based there has has helped
your business and then both hurt the
business a bit absolutely so I think the
biggest benefit of being in Canada is
the access to grant funding as well as
really great patient capital I think
that's really helped us do the initial
couple of years of research in R&D to
get to where we are today in terms of
limitations wise it's pretty pretty much
just Talent right and that's why we do
think that by being so close to the us
we can essentially have the Best of Both
Worlds by having two offices a lot of
companies today and especially a lot of
startups um are looking at ESG and
looking at you know the climate crisis
and doing things I think to kind of just
like tick a box and say okay you know
we're helping the environment but how
are you thinking about sustainability
since it's obviously at the the
Forefront of your brand um and is it is
there a personal mission that you're
motivated by absolutely so
sustainability is core to every single
person inside this company uh for me
personally I actually grew up in uh
China and one of the most polluted
cities so growing up I saw a bunch of
pollution smog everywhere so I thought
we need to be able to do something to
really help alleviate that interesting
and how how are you working to do that
now well so with our technology we
basically take organic waste feed stocks
that would otherwise go into landfills
and in the landfills they actually
release roughly uh 7% of greenhouse gas
emissions as they degrade right and so
by essentially diverting that stream
away from landfills and converting that
into composable Plastics we can
essentially offset a huge amount of
carbon emissions very cool now would you
ever consider selling your company and
if so what would it take well I haven't
actually considered selling the company
yet so ideally we like to go IPO one day
yeah very cool are there any big goals
or or dreams that you think of and they
can be as as lofty as possible well I
think the biggest goal for us is just to
see our products used in every single
person's homes right whether it be like
spoons and knives and Cutlery but also
to really great products that uh people
can take on a daily basis and as further
value
functionality is there one business rule
that you always operate by no matter
what I think the one business rule that
we always like to operate by is just
doing the right thing no matter how hard
it is uh sometimes it's a lot more
actually easier to do the wrong thing
and you know get by or tell a good story
and just get on with the day but um a
lot of times actually harder to do the
right thing so um yeah as much as
possible doing that yeah if you could go
back in time and tell yourself one piece
of advice the day before you launched
your company what would it
be I think if I were to go back in time
um the biggest advice I give to myself
is learn how to fail fast uh learn how
to basically experiment on ideas and
figure out what the most riskiest thing
element is to that drisk it first and if
it doesn't work then move on and and
basically just uh adjust course yeah so
what's it like to be a such a young
founder and be a a woman in a very male
dominated science heavy space I'd say I
think it's actually a privilege to be
honest um that uh I think because of who
we are like we actually really stand out
in the industry and a lot of times maybe
it's a negative but we like to see the
positive side of things and really use
it to our advantage so for example when
our company was first founded back in
2018 uh we actually won some great great
uh women P women founder Focus pitch
competitions and you know that was sort
of an exclusive access only we had
access to so um just really being able
to capitalize on that I think very cool
if you want you know these products in
everyone's homes how do you get people
to care specifically about you and what
you're doing so I think the key is to
really offer something that no other
product can offer right whether that's
functionality based where let's say phas
are hydrophobic so that means that may
prel water it's a great uh let's say
material right or that phas can be
really great for drug delivery in the
future right uh and that no other
bioplastics can do that so being able to
really do something that no other
bioplastic can do I think would be the
number one thing that makes people care
and how it relates to them as well the
other thing that's great about phas is
that phas is actually the fat of
bacteria and you make phas within your
body which means that phas are super
biocompatible and it doesn't cause any
issues when it's used in your body
within or without right so being able
ble to really find uh Niche fits of
where that's really great for human
health would be great because one other
thing that I'll share is that on a
weekly basis um you and I actually
consume roughly five grams which is a
credit card worth of plastics every
single week right so if that could be
made using phas much more in nerds your
com your body can actually digest it and
metabolize it then it's a lot more
better for human health um and what
would you like your legacy to
be I don't actually think too much about
my legacy um we really just want to make
the biggest impact that we can in in the
world so being able to have uh products
really just in every corner of everyone
everyone's lives that's I think the
biggest thing that would make us really
happy very cool well you've taught me so
much today Luna thank you so much thank
[Music]
you